c'était les matins qui commencent et
Adrien roart je n'en doute pas est en
pleine forme il nous attend bonjour
Adrien bon
bah je crois qu'on a perdu le son mon
cher Adrien on va essayer de vous
entendre c'est très rigolo du coup de
vous voir bouger l'élève sans vous
entendre ça il y en a récupéré le son
vous m'entendez cette fois je vous
demande simplement comment ça allait ce
matin Lucie
au Blanc-Mesnil c'est pas nous annonce
la décision
Beach Menil la plage artificielle n'aura
pas lieu et le motif est même écrit des
économies pour réparer les dégâts des
émeutes une annulation alors qu'ici un
habitant sur deux ne part pas en
vacances c'est le cas de ces enfants
rencontrer cet après-midi c'est un petit
peu dommage qu'on soit obligé de reculer
par rapport à quelques voyous qui
essaient de démolir notre démocratie
franchement je suis furieuse parce que
moi je m'attendais à faire mon aquagym
avec tous mes petits coachs habituels et
mes copines habituelles pour eux la
nouvelle est rude
je suis triste
parce que j'avais trop trop envie d'y
aller j'avais hâte on pourrait s'arroser
jouer dans le sable
bah ça on pourra pas le ressentir après
mais il y a aussi un autre objectif ces
gens qui malheureusement ne pourront pas
bénéficier de l'opération plage éphémère
et qui n'en sont pour rien dans les
émeutes peut-être qu'ils vont prendre en
main ces jeunes et qui vont leur dire
écoutez les gamins oh ça suffit
maintenant parce que vos conneries on
empathie tous c'est tout le quartier qui
empathie agite de l'air pour rien brasse
de l'air une politique mal vécue par la
plupart des habitants
moi j'ai un enfant qui est autiste là et
il a besoin de se dépenser c'est une
punition mais nous n'avons pas le choix
on ne peut pas y échapper
[Musique]
pour que tu existes on va t'acheter un
café un faux émirati débarque chez un
concessionnaire de voiture de luxe avec
une montagne de billets le client exige
ce qu'il y a de plus cher donne-moi
cette Mercedes cette Rolls Royce est
distribue des liasses de dirham aux
employés
mais la parodie n'a pas du tout fait
rire les autorités garde la monnaie
l'homme présenté comme asiatique a été
arrêté pour avoir donné une image fausse
et offensante de la société mirati il
est complètement givré
à 45 ans et en seulement 7 mois Brian
Johnson a réussi à rajeunir de 5 ans un
record
bienvenue dans le futur attention perte
d'âge
c'est-à-dire que son ADN a rajeuni et
surtout il vieillit et désormais 25%
plus lentement que la moyenne
[Musique]
une alimentation basée uniquement sur du
maïs provoque une carence en vitamine B3
à l'évidence cette carence le rend fou
et renforce son instinct agressif
après les émeutes la question des
sanctions revient dans le débat public
et le résultat est clair
73% des Français sont pour la
suppression des aides sociales pour les
familles des émeutiers dans le détail
les sympathisants de droite sont
majoritairement pour le oui atteint 91%
chez les républicains
95% rassemblement national et jusqu'à
98% à reconquête
avec à la clé cette macabre découverte
100% des femelles nourrit ainsi ont tué
leur propre petit à gauche le résultat
est plus mitigé seuls les sympathisants
du parti socialiste sont pour en
revanche les partisans de la France
insoumise sont contrat 57%, le chiffre
monte à 63% chez Europe Écologie Les
Verts
en France le bilan des 100 jours ce ne
sera pas pour demain Emmanuel Macron
l'avait promis pour le 14 juillet et
l'Élysée a finalement décidé de reporter
cette prise de parole le chef de l'État
s'exprimera dans les prochains jours le
mystère demeure en revanche un sur la
forme
particularité rare dans la nature
ces incisives poussent continuellement
tout au long de sa vie
mais je veux dire aller faire courir les
journalistes avec une Baba leurs ah non
on fait pas le faire le 14 je vais
peut-être le faire le 15 ou le 16 ou le
17 je cherche je crois que les Français
ils ont plus envie de jouer à ça
franchement ils ont plus envie de jouer
à ça donc encore une fois il n'a aucune
solution il n'a pas compris quel est le
problème il le dit lui-même d'ailleurs
37 ministres ou 40 ministres je sais pas
on a plus de 40 on n'a pas besoin qu'il
soit tout sur le pont sur un moment
comme ça le plus important c'est le
principe
l'administration citoyenneté a fait son
job c'est la patron du cipdr etc non
mais que le ministre de la Pêche ne soit
pas mobilisé sur les émeutes d'accord
que de la citoyenneté qui dépend de
Gérard Darmanin alors qu'on est dans un
problème de citoyenneté avec ses émeutes
très marrant l'ambiance
ah mais décidément Josy ne veut pas me
parler elle me met vent survente c'est
sûrement l'air marin ah il y avait pas
découvert mais c'est les couverts que
les gens non
[Musique]
normalement c'est fait et pourquoi ils
sont pas mis alors
[Applaudissements]
et ça continue
c'est que cette femme a eu le bon
réflexe elle a demandé à son chef
darmaninage tu as besoin de moi bon ben
non donc ça veut dire que ce ministère
ne sert à rien tu fais des économies et
en plus cette dame qui élue en
Nouvelle-Calédonie et donc elle passe
quasiment jamais son temps à Paris
fête nationale de non c'est moi qui l'ai
dit mais c'est le citier non pas du tout
malheureusement la fête nationale de
fait que le nom aujourd'hui
allez le dire aux élus qui ont dû
annuler les festivités allez le dire aux
élections annulé les festivités qui ne
dormaient pas la nuit pendant 5 jours et
qui craignent que ce soir on revive la
même chose
la voici en pleine action sur le point
de dérober la planche de sa victime un
surfeur effrayé quelques minutes
suffiront pour qu'il s'avoue vaincu face
à cette loutre agressive qui n'a pas
hésité à mordre le polyester forcément
ça donne lieu à des clichés insolites
l'animal connu pour ses siestes
paisibles à la surface de l'eau devient
amateur de glisse
et c'est ici derrière ces barreaux que
se termine peut-être pour de bon
l'odyssée du Grand Hamster l'affaire est
prise très au sérieux des avis de
recherche ont été placardés partout
après que la terreur des mers assez vite
quatre fois au large de Santa Cruz en
Californie